Tu no me vas a ganar en esfuerzo, desde tu Jet no me ganaras,
desde tu Bentley no me ganaras! En la vida cuando echas los dados, en el peor de los casos
caes en mediocre, asi que no seas mediocre porque si no tratas nada igual llegas a mediocre
YO SOY el mejor que jamas ha hecho esto! No porque me este comparando, sino por que no hay nadie como yo
YO SOY y tu problema es que todavia no has llegado a tu YO SOY!
Yo no puedo colgar algo frente a mi cara y simplemente quererlo porque no lo quiero. Y mucho de uds toman
lo que sea, porque no saben lo que quieren. Asi que si puedo hacer una cosa por uds antes de que se vayan de aqui
No quiero nada de uds aparte de que se vayan de aqui sabiendo lo que en realidad quieren!
Que quieren en sus matrimonios? Que quieren con sus hijos? Sus hijas? Que quieren como salud?
Que quieren economicamente? Cuanto dinero quieren hacer por año? Que cosas nuevas quieren hacer?
Como quieren vivir? Ya basta de levantarse en las mañanas como si fuese un accidente! Que quieren?
y cuando ya hayan conseguido lo que quieren, pasen el resto de su vida natural tratando de conseguirlo!
Levantandose y luchando por eso! La razon por la cual hablo con tanta pasion. Eric Thomas
por que hablas con tanta autoridad? porque estoy hablando sobre mi vida, no sobre algo que lei
yo comia de la basura, yo
no queria nada que ver con la basura, yo vivia en edificios abandonados, yo no queria nada con esos edificios!!
Pero Eric tu papa no estuvo en tu vida, tu mama te tuvo de adolescente, tu creciste en... pero mirate Eric
Por favor!! Eso no es una excusa. No hay excusas para que no estes viviendo tu potencial al maximo
no hay excusas!                        Regla #2. Trabaja con tus dones
Trabaja con tus dones...
Trabajar en mis dones
yo me di cuenta que todos nacimos con dones pero tenemos que pulirlos, sabes
no simplemente seras el mejor, hemos hablado de la escuela de la grandeza, sabes hablamos de que
la grandeza esta dentro de cada quien, pero yo me di cuenta que mi don no se iba a crear el mismo
mi don no se iba a nutrir el mismo, no se iba a perfeccionar el mismo
eso fue algo que yo tuve que hacer y asi sin darnos cuenta hicimos un video que se hizo viral
y creo que tiene mas de 50 millones de visitas y ahora nuestra pasion se convirtio en ganancia
Asi mismo! Convertimos nuestra pasion a ganancia.Me encanta! Si.
Regla #3 No Excusas. Saben que da pena?
Queremos que las personas nos garanticen cosas, pero nosotros mismos no estamos dispuestos de darnos garantias a nosotros mismos
Ahora escucha esa promesa de nuevo, alguien te hizo una promesa, 30 dolares
por 30 dias de garantia para hacer algo, y si en 30 dias no hacen lo te prometieron
en 30 dias llegas con una actitud demandando tu dinero de vuelta, pero NUNCA te has demandado el dinero de vuelta a ti mismo!
Nunca te has visto al espejo y TE has dicho, TU me defraudaste! Y hasta que no llegues as ese punto TU, TE defraudaste
Tu nunca lo has hecho, no eres lo suficientemente valiente! Tu lo quieres poner en los demas y decir
la razon por la cual no soy exitoso es por que mi jefe...
Alguna vez te has visto al espejo y dicho?: No me estoy levantando a tiempo, no estoy llegando al trabajo a tiempo.
No estoy dando el 120% de mi cuando estoy en el trabajo
Yo mismo me estoy defraudando. Y cuando llegues a ese punto de poder decirte eso. No me importa, escuchenme bien
Sin faltar el respeto. No me importa Glenn. Yo no lo hago por el, yo adoro a Glenn
Yo no vine a hacer lo que se hacer para que Glenn me recomiende, para que Glenn me sobe la espalda
Yo estoy mas preocupado por MI que por lo que piensa Glenn de MI. Yo tengo mis estandares, tengo mis valores
No me importa cuanto me pagues, si doy charla en una escuela primaria por 300$ es porque lo escojo
por $300, si escogi hablar en una carcel gratis yo
escogi eso. Y yo no les voy a dar menos a los prisioneros que a alguien que me pague $300 mil por que?
porque yo me valoro lo suficiente para darles mi 120% a todos o no lo hago. Ese es el problema con muchos de uds.
siempre quieren culpar a otros, siempre quieren quemar a los demas
Pero porque no se echan al fuego uds mismos? Cuando estas dando de ti 50%? Te debes una explicacion.
Te debes una explicacion!!!
Tienes que mirarte al espejo y preguntarte por que estas dando solo 50%? Que diablos te pasa?
Tienes que castigarte. Te tienes que decirte basta de TV, basta de pasapalos. Basta de postres, ya basta!!
No, ahora lo vamos a solucionar. No, no mas alcohol. No por ahora
no puedo con eso por ahora.TU tienes que decirte a TI que TE debes algo! Ya deja de regresar
Te la pasas regresando al mall con el recibo diciendo. Esto fue lo que me prometieron. Glenn no hiciste lo que me prometiste
Pues no hicieron lo que me prometieron
Por que, yo? Tengo que hacer algo por uds?
Se tienen que ir de este cuarto debiendose algo. Yo no llegue hasta donde estoy dando excusas.
Que importa si mi padre no estuvo en mi vida, la verdadera realidad es que el nunca vendra!
Entonces me voy a pasar el resto de mi vida esperandolo? El no va a venir! Yo vivo en America
Soy un hombre Afro-americano, aqui no nos tratan igual. Se llama racismo. No voy a llorar por eso
Probablemente va haber racismo hasta despues que yo muera. Pero no voy a llorar por eso. Igualmente me volvere millonario.
I'm still gonna be one of the top motivational speakers in the world
No, I didn't grow up on that side of the town. No, my mama don't have no network
No, I don't know a whole lot of people. No, I'm not at a country club
No, I don't play golf and I don't plan on playing no time soon, but I'm still gonna be successful
I'm still gonna get to where they are why cuz I owe it to myself and can't nobody stopped me put me you
Need to get rid of them excuses. You need to stop pointing fingers at people and you start pointing fingers at yourself
What is you not doing renumber for upgrade your values? God asked me about two months ago
He said et if there's one mistake you made what's that one mistake? You made I saw me be honest with you
My values are not in alignment with my dreams
He said what do you mean by that I said I want to tell you a story
I got a good friend of mine who you know a good friend of mine. He came to me say Eric
My marriage is not where my marriage needs to be. I need to make some adjustments
I see you and your wife. I see how much time you spend with your wife
How much time you spend with your children, and I just I want that you buy your wife roses regularly
You're always taking her out to eat like yeah, I'm watching you you'd spoil her et. But I just what can I do?
And so I told him what they're doing. Guess what he started doing god. He started doing the exact same thing
I started doing he said Erica's not working
Like I'm doing exactly what you're doing, but it's not working. I said he said why isn't it working?
So, you know why it's not working because your values and your dream you say you say you want a better marriage
But I told you you need to I on your wife's clothes
You know what? He told me after why I said I'll be honest with you here
I know you told me the iron coming to wash he told me to cook but where I come from
Beyond here
When I do that
I feel like a punk and I said that's why you're having a hard time doing it because your
Value system says a man is not supposed to iron a man is not supposed to cook a man is not supposed to wash dishes
That's what your value system says. So you're doing one thing but you're going to get your own value system
the reason why I'm having such an easy time washing clothes and cooking and
Irony, you know why because nothing is as important to me as my marriage and I would rather be happy
I would rather be happy than they say. I ain't no Punk. Let make me a bunk. I want to be a bunk
a
Happy punk
Girl no a friend of Mines
He came to my house and I didn't have a mop
and so I was on the ground and I was mopping the floor with a towel and he says II Tina if I'm free you're
On the ground and you're mopping I said, yeah. He says your wife got you whipped. I said you didn't know
You just found it out
I've been doing a terrible job. I'm sorry. I am with and after 23 years you should be and if you're not it's a problem
So listen to me there those of you said I want to be a millionaire
I want to be the best at this company
right
But your value system says you believe in sleep more than you believe in grinding
Your value system says you are a consumer and not a producer that
you're spending more money than you're making why because you're a
conservator you're reading all the books and you're saying everything the books are saying but those books are not in alignment with your values and
You're gonna go to the next level your values are gonna have to change rule no.5 you reap what you sow
I think what people get confused is you know
They're grinding with a goal and I'm not saying you should have goals
But you should be grinding for Brian and said, you know, you should grind because that's what you do
You're passionate about what you do
you know and so you wake it up every day with this concept of I have
24 hours and they're mine this 24-hour belongs to me
Right and whatever I doing is 24 hours will determine where I'll be tomorrow and the next day
I think that's what people need to focus on like get off of this. I want to make six figures
I want to try this car. I want to live in this out
I think what people should be focusing on is I have
24 hours like Oprah only has 24 that field dates only asking me for like Warren Buffett only has
24 hours and then that 24 hour period I can even break my life or make my life nothing
And I'm not saying you should have goals don't
I just think that goes for people is too high on the priority list and I think what should be on the priority list is
Going to bed
So you can wake up
next day and you can grind it out and I'm just a dude that believes you reap what you sow so if you're
Grinding or money grind it on Tuesday grind it on Wednesday if you're grinding six seven days a week
For four span of five or six years something's got to come under that shirt
But if you're only grinding, you know a Monday you fired up Wednesday. He's back you're sleeping in
Thursday you gotta eat the farm of the world is like like I heard people say come dance
With these hump day
Like money off day two days up day like every day is hump day
And I think if we would spend more time on what's my goal, you know meaning?
What do I need to accomplish in this day to live this lifestyle and you go after it then?
I think I think more you will be successful
Rule number six education is the great equalizer
I just ran across a quote the other day that says
Education is the great equalizer
And I was like, oh, so no matter where you are
If you feel like you started at the bottom, you know, if you feel like you started at the top
But you want to preserve the top because just because you're at the top don't mean you gonna be at the top forever
I mean you look at great football players, you know great football teams
I mean, you're not you're not gonna automatically win because of your name
You have to keep performing year after year
So if you're at the bottom and you're like man, I'm at the bottom Eric and I want to live life like everybody else
I want to fly first-class like I want to see the world, you know, I don't want any limitations then
Reading is not not
Okay
So I'm using the word reading but what I'm saying is education being enlightened
being
Informed and I had to realize for myself being a high school
Dropout like you can't use that excuse forever where I was born and where I was raised you can't use that forever
And so to me, you liberate yourself Malcolm
You talked about Malcolm Malcolm liberated himself and most people don't know Malcolm was not born
wearing glasses like Malcolm had 20/20 vision
But it was in prison when Malcolm learned to take reading serious and he read with a dim light at night. That's how he
Eventually lost his sight, but he lost his sight, but he gained his vision
You know, he lost his sight, but he gained his vision at that point
So I would say the young people who are watching us that is not optional the more you read the more
Liberated you are and the more you are educated of
To me the the more you can experience a life
Like the people that you're probably looking at and saying I wish I could live like that person. Yeah rule number seven
What is your why what's your why hey if I don't get y'all nothing else?
you better start that what's your why you know why I do what I do and I do it so passionate because my grandfather was
A high school dropout. My father was a high school dropout. I was a high school dropout and we bout to break the cycle
I do what I do so my son won't have to go through what I went through
When I was at the football game my old do one with me
I saw other kids with a file I said I don't never happen to me
I do what I do because my daughter says she's going to Hartford ain't even about y'all
I'm about to come here blaze y'all why cuz I'm trying to get you all the NFL
I ain't bout to miss this opportunity
This is the first NFL team I've ever done in my life, and I'm about to lick it
I'm about to give everything I got and I will know if I won't get another gig it won't having to do with the fact
That I didn't put everything on the field
What's your why why do you wake up in the morning? Why do you put on that jersey
Why do you go out and practice? Why rule number eight have boundaries? I have a ritual where?
even if you're my closest friend, I
Have boundaries, so just because it's my company. It doesn't mean I can take calls all day, right?
I have boundaries so you can't call me in a certain time why I'm working
so I'm on the phone all day and I'm saying this to
Entrepreneurs because one of the gaps and we'll talk about this later in the show
But you got to find a gap and one of the gaps that entrepreneurs is that they feel like because they own their day
They can spend it like they want you cannot spend it like you want to you saw if you were working for IBM
Or you're working for for where are you working for?
You could be on the all day at a major corporation talking on a pole
So so why do you allow yourself to talk on the phone with your business? My FAQ is yours?
You should probably you should make sure there's no phone calls for your business
So one of my rituals is when I get started there are no interruptions when I get started
I don't care if it's my wife my children. They know that from a certain time train
I'm going all in and I can't go all in and answer the phone. I can't go all in and watching TV in distraction
I can't go in with the distraction
And so some entrepreneurs are like why am I not blown up because you don't want you're not in abstraction
You don't have that that that moment of your day
I don't care if it's two hours four hours where you shut in tire whirl out. No Twitter. No Facebook
No you no thing. No Instagram
We love that in Segawa, so we're just the two hours
I'm going in and once I come out then we can do Instagram not be honest
your content probably would be stronger if you had that that time of isolation of
solitude where you give yourself a chance to think you give yourself a chance to go in and when you go in you go a
Hundred and twenty percent. So yeah, I like that rule number nine speak from the heart I think was so unique about
You know, my presentation is that it comes from the heart
You know that I speak from the heart and I'm not afraid to be transparent. I'm not afraid to talk about my failures
I'm not I'm not afraid to talk about my fears
You know, I'm not I'm not afraid to open up my life and give my story to the world
Rule number ten succeed as bad as you want to breathe
If you want to make six figures you can't just be talking about you want to make six figures
You hear what I'm saying you tonight if you do the three things I tell you to do tonight
I
Guarantee, whatever it is you want to do in life?
You'll be able to do you will be able to accomplish whatever you want to academically
Financially relationally, whatever so three things. All right now, I'm gonna tell you the story
I got to get out of here and the stories about you guys have probably heard about this before it was a
It was a young man who you know
He wanted to make a lot of money
And so he went to this guru right and he told the Guru, you know
I want to be on the same level you are and so the Guru said if you want to be on the same level I'm
All I'll meet you tomorrow at the beach at 4:00 a.m
He liked the beach I said I wanna make money I don't want to swim
Guru said if you want to make money, I'll meet you tomorrow
4:00 a.m. So the young man got there 4:00 a.m. He already to rock and roll got on the suit
He should have wore shorts the old man grabs. His hand said how bad do you want to be successful? He said real bad
He said walk on out in the water
So he walks out into the water watch this when he walks onto the water it goes waist-deep
So he liked this guy crazy up a dream like I wanna make money. He got me on your swimming
I didn't ask to be a lifeguard. I don't want to make money
He got me in so he said come on a little further walked. I looked further then he had it right around at this area
The stove the area so this old man crazy he making money, but he crazy
Said come on out a little party. Can I look farther? I was right at his mouth my man
Like I'm about to go back in here. This God is mine
So the old man said I thought you said you wanted to be successful
He said I do he said walk a little further. He can't drop this head in held him down. Hold him down
My man didn't scratch it. Hold him down. I got you. I know you brushed it out, but I got you
He'll down. I need you for illustration. He had him held down just before my man was about to pass out. He raised him up
He said I got a question for you. Somebody answer the question for me
He said when you were under water, what did you want to do?
Lee I'm looking for a different word than live what's that were said I wanted to breathe
He told the guy he said when you want to succeed as bad as you want to breathe then you'll be successful I
Don't know how many y'all got asthma here today
But if you ever had an asthma attack before you short of breath and so be shortness of breath you wheezing
The only thing you trying to do is get some air you don't care about no basketball game you don't care
What's on TV you don't care about nobody calling you. You don't care about a party
The only thing you care about when you're trying to breathe is to get some fresh air
That's it
and when you get to the point where all you want to do is be
Successful as bad as you want to breathe then you'll be successful
And I'm here to tell you number one that most of you say you want to be successful
But you don't want it bad. You just kind of want it. You don't want it badder than you want a party
You don't want it as much as you want to be cool
You most of you don't want success as much as you want to sleep
some of you love sleep more than you love success and I'm here to tell you today if you're going to be
Successful, you've got to be willing to give up sleep
You got to be willing to work off for three hours of sleep two hours
If you really want to be successful some days you will have to stay up three days in a row
Because if you go to sleep you might miss the opportunity to be successful
That's how bad you got a warning you got to go days when I listen to me. You got to want to be successful
So bad that you forget to eat
Beyonce said once she was on the sand doing her thing three days had gone by she forgot she didn't eat
Because she was engaged I never forget when 50-cent was doing his movie
I did a little research on 50 and 50 cent that when he wasn't doing the movie
He was doing the soundtrack and they when do you sleep 50 sleep?
He said sleep sleep is for those people who are broke. I
Don't sleep
Said I got an opportunity to make a dream become a reality
Football players how many football players?
I got anybody like football in here raise your hand here. I like football
Emmitt Smith I used to be a cowboy fan before they get my boy Tom Landry wrong
I used to be a cowboy fan
And why since there was a commercial Emmitt Smith had won his first Super Bowl and he had this commercial when he was lifting weights
I don't know if you saw the commercial he was flipping and he said he said image said you know what?
I won the Super Bowl so I can rest now
He was doing his bench press so he said I want a Super Bowl so I can rest now
So he throws over about 325 boom and he rests for about two seconds
Woohoo, woohoo! Woohoo
You see that he'd already won a Super Lawyer
he said I think I'm gonna take a rest and he rests my how long one second most of you won't be successful because when
You're studying and you get tired you quit
And I'm here to tell you today if you got it somebody came to my office the other day crying
I said look, don't cry to give up cry to keep going
Don't cry to quit
You already in pain you already hurt get a reward from it
Don't go to sleep
Until you succeed
Listen to me. I'm here to tell you today that you can come here
You can jump up you can do flips you can be excited when we give away money
But listen to me, you'll never be successful in. I don't have to give you a dime to do what you do
You won't be successful until you say I don't need that money
Because I got it in here
So listen to me Emmitt Smith said this at the end of the commercial Emmitt Smith saying all men are created equal
some work harder in pre-season
I'ma say it again because you might have missed it. All men are created equal some work harder in pre-season
So that means that there are some people who are going to see the professor
Going to see the TA and even when the professor says I don't meet with you my ta meets with you you say I want
to talk to your TA I
Don't pay the TA I pay you to teach me
So you won't have to find some time to meet me if I got to meet you at the mall if I got to meet
You at your house you are going to see me listen to me
All men are created equal some work hard in pre-season when I went to college guys were waiting smarter than me for point OS
3.0. They went to the Ivy League high schools came to oak board from these great high schools
Most of them are not doing what I'm doing why cuz it's not about where you come from
It's about heart you come to a place where you know being smart ain't enough. You got to have heart
That's number one. Watch. Number two. Number two catch. Number two. I wrote it down. I want to make sure you got it
It says to be watch this watch this we're talking about sacrifice now
The important thing is this you're writing why I'm saying it because I only have about three more minutes
Listen to me
the most important thing is is to be able at any moment to
Sacrifice what you are for what you will become
That's the number two thing, you've got to catch that one
To be able to listen to me at any moment
Some of you you can make sacrifices when Monday Night Football is not all you can make a sacrifice
But when the game come on for some reason you just attach to it
For some of you when your favorite show come on you can be you can make sacrifices on Sunday when they not going on
but when your favorite show comes on Monday BAM
Some of you focus into the phone ring and you like I gotta answer it if I don't answer the phone, I'm gonna die
I'm saying you today that there's some of you if you give up your cell phone you would be successful
But your cell phone is more important to you than your success
I'm gonna sit against I'm gonna hurt somebody I'm gonna hurt somebody
Some of you need to give up your cell phone because the time you spend on your cell phone could be used for your success
The time you could be using
to be successful you're using on the cell and the cell phone is not bringing you nothing but a bill and
Somebody has told you you couldn't live without it
I'm sorry going deep now giving up stuff
Watch what it says to be able at any moment to sacrifice what we are for what we could be
I don't do well in math. You're right. You hadn't never studied
I'm not good in writing because you have never written before
But I dare you to fail in writing for a whole year to see if you can get to the end I
Dare you to fail my dad you take that same class over and over guys
I dare you to stop dropping classes. Like you saw I
Always want to give up. I'm dropping. Why are you dropping?
I'm so grateful that the sliding's didn't drop and quit say I'm just gonna stop I'm a slave. I'm just gonna be a slave
I'm a quit. Listen to me. The slave said we will live because one day we will become rule number 11 push through it
There's anything in life that you don't currently
Now it's because of who you are and how you think
Come on right now you saying et man? You talking to me man? I'm going through some type of pain
I'm ready to quit and give up. Let me see. You ain't I'm ready to quit and give up
Let me see n something in life. I'm ready to quit on give up on come on raise your hand
I'm ready to quit on I'm ready to give up on it. Come on, raise it up
alright
What I need you to do is I need you to find a reason to keep going and if you can find a reason to
Keep going
I know you're strong enough to do it cuz you helmet
then every human has what it takes to get past whatever they going through if they decide to
push through it
Rush through it
Tragedy and trials come to everybody only the strong survive why I watch my wife when she got diagnosed
I watched my wife have terrible days and she didn't probably miss two days of work the whole time. She had MS
I watched her go to work and I'm like boo. Why in the world would you get up and go to work?
You don't even need the money
Why would you do it is cold?
His 10 degrees in Michigan and your MS flare-up when it's cold. What are you doing? She said I can't see my daughter
I can't have my door to see me weak
Is my daughter gonna be married one day
And my daughter gonna face tragedy one day and I have to show her how to do it
So I get up and get dressed and I'm gonna work every day
So my baby girl can know how to get through trials
Cuz one day she ain't gonna be under our roof and she gonna have to do it alone
And I don't want to talk. I want to model what it looks like
My daughter got on the prayer line through the prayer meeting up today told her testimony
So I you and you feel like going to school
I feel like walking a mile to go to class and I thought about it. My mom got a chronic illness
My mom and her forties can get up with a chronic
Illness and go to work while surely I can get up at 18 years old and go to class
It worked
Listen to me very closely y'all running from obstacles
when in fact is the obstacle that's gonna take you to the next level like y'all running from pain y'all running from
Challenges you telling me how difficult your life is. Do you understand?
It is the difficulty that's gonna prepare you and take you to that next level. Why do you keep crying mommy God?
Why don't I get you man? Why don't I get cancer? Why did my mama died? Why did I get fired? Do you understand?
listen
You got through that you got put through that because what that does that tension produces brightness?
Not running from it and run through it. Y'all y'all got it hear me
The reason why you do what you do is more critical than what you thought and if why you do what you do is weak
I need you to go back and start all over again because if your reasoning is weak, you're not gonna get it done
Why?
Because light is going to beat you upside your head and I'm gonna tell you this I don't care who you are and what profession
You in before you blow up light will strip you to the core
but if you wait
you will be broke and I'm not here because I'm the best I'm here because they tried to break me and they could
rule number 12 be ready to seize all
Opportunities many of you have a very small opportunity and you're not taking advantage of that opportunity
Because you're not thinking about the next opportunity looking at this as small
No, this is the gateway like this is the first one right so you got to ask yourself this question
Like how do you keep that fire? You know how you keep it?
You keep putting different opportunities in front of you. You keep setting different opportunities. Anybody know who this is
Yeah, you sure here in the Big Ten. He gave us the business. You should know he is yo, yogi. Ferrell didn't get drafted
Didn't get drafted to the NBA
Didn't get drafted, but they just something happened the other day to Dallas Mavericks needed a player they gave my man a 10-day contract
I much did he make
Know how much LeBron make it a million. They are my men looking for 10 days
You just wants you to play for somebody got hurt. We are gonna bring you in for 10 days
He'll say you got 10 days ride the bitch, you know do your thing, but you only got 10 days. Don't get your hopes up
My man been coming in I'm talking about
Schrick, boom not only three-pointers like daggers 2 seconds
Boom the 10-day contract then turn it is boy bout to get a contract. What are you doing with your opportunity?
We all get one we all get your 10-day contract
But the question is with our 10-day contract run into a gear contract when they turn into a two-year contract
You think yogi Pharaohs the only one who's got the opportunity to come from the Developmental League and play?
No, you think other people doing Lee doing no why because they weren't prepared for what are you doing in the dark when nobody's watching?
What are you doing in the dark 10-day contract, but he didn't come in and say I only got 10 days
That's what some of y'all own. Oh just only got 10 days. I might only give 10 days work for effort
I might as well to give 10 days worth the energy Yogi
Berra was like I'm about to act like this might be my last shot
I'm about to act like I'm starting. I'm about to act like LeBron. I'm about to act like Kyrie. I'm about to act like Stepford
You put me in the game. I'm telling you. I'm not the murderer and after 10 game keeping murdering them
He's been on ESPN almost every day all they talk about yogi fair
I'm talking about NBA TV ESPN. 1 espn2 like Spanish TDS being so y'all gotta understand something
What was your view? What was yogi doing before? What was yogi to him before? He got that opportunity? Yo
He was preparing for it
You don't get in the game and score like he scored
So he said so what I didn't make the league, so what they can't stop me from practicing
They can't stop me from getting up in the morning and running drills
So the problem most of you is you have an opportunity you wrote it down. You wrote it down right here opportunity
They gave me an opportunity. They gave me a shot. Somebody gave me a GED. I turn that gene into a four-year degree
Somebody gave me a four-year degree. I turn it into a master's degree. Somebody gave me a master's degree
I turn it to a PhD you got the opportunity what you're doing with it
Opportunity is government will you'll be writing when it comes rule number 13, don't do it alone
There are those of you who have dreams and goals and you not getting it you cannot do it alone
Are you hearing me and I feel you I feel you like you feel like like if you do it by yourself
For real like you don't have to deal with people
You have to go through some of the stressors of dealing with people on you
Like I just want to be by myself
I want to do it by myself and look I'm not mad at you
But I'm telling you there's a level that you can get to alone and then there's a level you can get you
Are you hear me?
There's a level you can get to it's two more look it was it was the three of us initially Carl myself
CJ we call ourselves a three-headed monster the head right the hands right come on in the mouth
Are you hearing what I'm telling you and so listen to me?
Y'all gotta hear what I'm telling you y'all gotta hear what I'm telling you watch this the power of two
So the Belgian horse, come on, come on. Come on kid. Make sure you show an image of them
I need them to see how strong that horse in I didn't see the power
This horse has the ability like this is just like general horse. We ain't about the more powerful
Seven thousand pounds are you hearing me?
7,000 pounds it could pull on its own
unbelievable, but watch this it's gonna blow your mind, but when you put two of them together,
Yep, you have two of them together. They can actually pull it just like general light they can pull
15,000 five you did you hear what I just said
Alone, they can do seven right together 15, not 14
but watch this ah my blowing watch this, but if you train them together, this will my boy Justin talking but boy
Justin it's a mental. You have mental skills coach, right? Here's what he taught me
He said when you put two of them together and train them together from the beginning Karl
This is gonna blow your mind. They can pull
25,000 pow
Come on come on alone seven both of them together 15, but if you train them together
If you try I'm trying to tell y'all you try to do it alone and nothing great has ever been done a little
And so I know you feel more comfortable being by yourself. I know it's easier to be by yourself
Look, I know you like being by yourself, but I'm telling you some of them gold. You got a baby
come on, some of them ideas you had so I'm gonna stop you want to accomplish its
25,000 pounds, you know your best day. You can't do that by yourself sois your boy ichi-san listen to me. Come on, come on
^ - I know there's a power in one but the power of two is
Great rule number fourteen do not be outworked. You will not outwork me
It's not about being the best motivational speaker in the world. It's about being the most consistent motivational speaker in the world
and so when you watch me even if you don't like me, and you're into motivation
You gotta fool with me why cuz I'm on everything a team was that you wanted Knicks commercial? Yep
It was you do this day after
Dedicating your life to the search for a few more feet Ichi. You're doing stuff with the Olympics. Absolutely et
Was that too old it? Yep. That was me Ichi. Did you do that yet?
You saw me what you doing self or Cleveland or WTF? That was me. You will not outwork me
High school dropout. Yes, your vocabulary count is deeper than mine. Yeah. Absolutely. Yep
You look better than me suit asymmetric. Look up you got me beat all day
You got me grew up on the other side of town two pairs great Network
You got I'm not gonna lie you way sweeter than I am
You got all the stuff you got you got it all but you will not
Outwork me cuz your height has nothing doing my work ethic your face has meta doing my workout
Yo too bad background had never doing my work as you well know. I worked me Oh georgette
You will not work me in your bed, Leigh. You will not work me and there does of you in this room
The reason why this stuff ain't happening for you cuz you gettin out words. Come on call the best motivational speakers in the world
Give us seven days. Let us go over the world and speak. Come on
And why are you in the green room putting on your makeup? You will not work me I'm being real
You will not outwork me while you do a photo shoot
You won't I work in job being outworked in your marriage. You're being outworked in your job your been out work with your kids
Your kids in the gang why cuz somebody living on the more you love alone
In a gang then the gang cuz you ain't hardly at all
You've been out worked you got somebody else in the hood who got more?
They got your kid here more. Do you got them and you like I just can't believe this society day
It's not this society you got out worked
Some dude up the block. It's get it spending more time with your son
You are some guy on the Block is telling your daughter how cute she is
Are you not cuz you're grinding you work in but you thought when I told you 120, I just made it work
I mean everywhere you will not outwork me you might make money
But your marriage might not be I'm gonna get you on all fronts
rule number 15 face your fears where every milestone
While you might be excited about the milestone, there's a part of the milestone that you don't want to face
Are you hearing me and listen to me? I'm not out the coursework. Boom. Got it done in order
ET why did it take you two years?
ET after you finished your coursework. Why did it take you two years to get started with the dissertation?
I'm gonna be 100 with you there one look knocked all the coursework out
But when I finally got to the dissertation I had to get to that demon I had to deal with it
I had to face it face one. We're not talking about elementary school middle school high school
I've had a professor or two tell me in college
that you will never get your dissertation that that that while you're writing has improved but in terms of your
Analysis, like you are not critical enough to do a dissertation. Are you hear what I'm telling you? We're talking about look math
I love math coming up why it is what it is
So, please excuse my dear Aunt Sally like it is what it is. Right? It's not subjective writing is subjective
I've had teachers to look at my work and and ship it in the park and the fear to fear what the fear of rejection
Right. This is if my teachers were so subjective. I put my whole heart into it
I put everything I could push and they tell me edit it again a
revision after revision
add it after edit our you hear what I'm telling you I had to deal with the fact that
writing has never really been my strong suit and even though I've worked hard and I'm putting in hours and hours in the back of
My mind I in the back of my mind I could hear the teacher say et
You'll have what it takes to get a dissertation. I'm a grown man dealing with that fear
I'm a grown man of dealing with the rejection of getting all that read
All that read on my paper of having to do it over and over and over and over and come on
Come on. Somebody fills me you feel like you'll do a hundred and twenty percent
You'll give everything you have and it still won't be enough. I feel you
I was there a part of the milestone is what does I give everything and it ain't enough?
what if I put my whole heart my whole my
Solar to an ET and it's not enough. What am I doing? And I fail
And so I feel you so you're just like you're not gonna do it at all
Because you rather not do it and find out the truth, and I'm telling you got to do me a favor
We gotta face your fear and you guys do it. Anyway, you're sweaty. Had to face his fear. That's right. Yup
I know you CET be small and you write I am be small
But it don't mean be smart without fear and don't mean be smart without lure anxiety
It don't mean be small and I'm just 120 percent. Sure
No, I have to live by faith - and I made up in my mind ET you've got to go after eat
Look, I finished my coursework
It took me two years why cuz it took me two years to get over the fear
It took me two years to get over the anxiety it took me two years to finally say Goliath here
I come Goliath you might be taller than me. You might be bigger than me
You might be stronger than me, but I'm coming and I'd rather die trying
I'd rather die going after this dissertation. I'd rather give everything our guy really give a year
I'd rather put in work and
fail
You cannot try it off rule number 16 focus on the positives
Where your focus goes your energy flows?
and so if you focusing on the negative guess what's going to happen your energy is going to go to the negative of everything and
Everything is gonna be negative because that's where your focus is. That's where your energy is flowing
Listen to me if you think about that thing with you concentrate on winning you concentrate on
Dominating listen to me
Whatever you focus on your when your focus goes your energy flows
And so we gonna think about what we're thinking about you hear me
We're gonna think about what we're thinking about
And when we think about those things which are pure listen to me come all that stuff. That's true. Right. Are you whatsoever?
Things are pure whatsoever. Things are true. Whatsoever. Things are lovely whatsoever things of a good rapport
Are you hear me meditate on this stuff focus on this stuff?
It don't mean negative thing will happen, but we not focusing on it
Are you hearing me and don't mean that negative things won't transpire that as you go through the day something bad will happen
But we're not gonna meditate on it. We don't focus on what's positive
we gonna focus on what's good, right and when we focus on that
That's where our energies gonna go and what's gonna happen is the outcomes are gonna reflect our thinking rule number 17
Practice practice practice practice practice practice reps reps reps. I can't wait to the big gigs to speak
I got to get my reps in I don't care how good you are
I don't care how bad you are you got to get those reps in. So make sure you do this
Listen to me and I told you how many times a day. Do I want you doing this?
Three times a day morning noon
Night, come on. This ain't rocket science. I want you to do a win
Morning, noon night
One that's not a lot of us. Let me hear you morning noon
night
90 straight days. All right. So y'all know we went from the backyard we did this here, right?
We did we did we did high schools like fruit just keep practicing. It ain't rocket science
You keep doing it 30
Days 90 you start all over
you go to another level 30 days 60 to 80 90 day you like why am I not going to that because you're not doing
30 days a day 9 day
Now you might not even make it like you might not even whatever you say he was gonna do it might not need last 30
Days, you might do 10 and quit
Once y'all win it all do you even know?
Like do you know what you'll win it? All is for this year
Like do you know if this year ended like what you gonna?
Happen like do you know or you're just waking up playing craps with your life?
You just hope it roll on what you wanted to roll on. You playing a lottery with your life
You're just hoping you put the numbers in and they come out right or you 1369
30 60 90 more the new Knights make the adjustments whatever you're doing. That's not good. Quit you're getting like a D
I see. Okay. We do you got 71% You're doing something wrong. Look if you've got an 80% you're doing something what?
If you've got an 89% you're doing some work
Oh, you might be sweet 89 might be sweet, but we got an 11 percent below. There's a leprosy work right there
It's not until you getting 100% then you need to stop right? So 30 60 90. Say it with me 30 60 90
Come on, 30 60 not and then we do what?
We start all over again by that time. It's a habit
If you really want to be dominant in your field 30 60 90 start all over again
30 60 nights taught all of gear morning unite rule number 18
Execute. All right guys, I've been watching the Olympics. Yeah. Yeah
I've been watching the Olympics right my favorite part. You have track and field. Nope. I'm not talking one who say bulk
No, don't we know net. Nope. I'm talking about the false starts. Yeah, I love it. Yep. You say inkeater course start. Yeah
Yeah, because I'm tired of people asking me he why are you so passionate? Yeah, I'm tired of people saying et
Why you so loud et. Why you aggressive? Why because the real world? Yep
The real world is like track and field and I don't know if you've been watching or if you paid attention
But you get one false start. Yup. That's it guys. You'll get one false start. That's it
Like you don't get a second chance and what I love about these are lipids
We don't show it to you what I love about these Olympics is one false start you out. That's right
You've been working for four straight years you out
Absolutely. Don't get a second shot
I like all that stuff you missed you made some serious sacrifices like you got an early in the morning
Like, you know what I'm saying? Like you didn't go out with your homies, right?
Look, there's no some things that you have to give up for four straight years
You've been getting up in the morning four straight years. You've been grinding four straight years
You've been eating different for a straight years
You've been in the weight room boy straight years you've been going in and you ruined it all
you've ruined all with false start and you can't say well I didn't mean to do this it I didn't mean to do that and
I made a mistake. There are no mistakes
And that's why I get so passionate because in the real world
You don't get five six seven chances and some of you were going through life
You wonder why you're not
Successful you wonder why you average you wonder why you can't live the way you deserve to live
You wonder why you would lie
You wonder why you keep coming up short you think cause you say you sorry you keep saying I didn't mean it you keep saying
I my heart's in the right place look in the real world is like track and field
They don't care you get one call star boom and you out so your boy et is passionate
why do I tell you that you gotta make
Sacrifices and you got to get up to three o'clock and fork hot and you gotta grind eat
Why are you telling me that why because people don't need help sleeping people don't need help gaining weight
People don't need help over indulging making excuses. People don't need help hitting the snooze button
People need help making sacrifices. So it's your boy et telling you. Look I'm not saying it's gonna be easy
I didn't make up the rules. I'm not saying you don't need a 34 chair
I didn't make up the rules
But what I'm telling you is life is like track and field and Rio you don't always get another one
You don't always get a second one. You don't always get a third one. You don't always get a full when yes, it's tough
It's hard. Listen to me if it was easy to stay focused when it's done
Like everybody would do it if it was easy to jump off where the brain start everybody was doing
I'm not telling you as won't be easy to get up in three blocks of moon
I'm not telling you it's gonna be easy to sacrifice. I'm not telling you it's gonna be easy to drive
I'm not telling you it's going to be easy, but I can tell you this it will be worth the
Sacrifice if you can grind your way through it, so like who say no no excuses. Just
adjustments execute my friend
execute
Leading my 19 shut it all down and listen
Let me just explain something y'all I gotta keep it watered CJ 12 years younger than me
I was out of high school before this boy was even really born. Are you hearing what I'm saying?
my man 12 years younger than me 12 years and he picked up that phone and he had a
He had one of them are the heart
Do you have anybody in your inner circle that's willing to be real with you that's willing to keep it 100
That don't care none about your feelings, but they care about your goals and your dreams
CJ hit me up. I called my man love for message. Like see they killing me
They want to know when the mixtape coming out. When is the next mixtape coming out? See see said et
Let me tell you something shut it down
I said what he said shut it down shut the television ain't no mixtape coming. Stop doing T G
I shut it down. That's why you got the reruns for so long. He said shut it down. He shut it down
I'm tired. He said we'll keep it walking. I'm tired eat the last true mixtape you was talking about how you're gonna get your PhD
Between me and you amano he model man
The man we will not come out with another mixtape were you talking about what you gonna do? Shut it all down
Eat, do you understand that that the future of this company is on you finishing his ph.d
Shut the gigs down
Shut it down and I'm telling y'all
One of the best up one of the ways your boy got the mild stuff done
I had to shut it down. I shut down the phone call flatout from a certain time
Don't call my house
If you love me text me if you love me and they know emergency don't go I had to shut it down shut the TV
Down listen to me put the controllers down shut down going out
So lit on the weekend more than a club look shut it down shut down on your favorite team
It's not watching your favorite football or basketball or fuck whatever it is
Shut it down and I'm telling you you ain't got to set it down for the rest of your life
But you got to set it down long enough so you can get your balls on
Yeah, so you can get your NBA final done. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, so you get your World Series done. Yep. Are you here?
So you don't national titles? Oh, are you hearing me so you can get joke book done
So you just Joe CDs finish so you can get your degree so you can take your marriage to the next level shut it down
I had to shut the noise down
I had to shut it down when I shut it down when I shut certain things down in my life
Boom, I went to a whole other level rule number 20 leave your mark and there those of you
Who don't understand the power of your wife and what I need you to do for me
Is that when you make your moves on a daily basis, I don't need you to make them with you on your brain
Because if you're thinking about you
You might quit well if you think about you
You might give me 80% right if you're thinking about you like real you you won't you you selfish
like really some of y'all you go to work and you like I don't feel like going to work and
The reason why you don't feel like going to work as you own you
So you cannot want to go to work and then when you go you like real this is what people don't realize
We didn't blow up because of what we do we blow up because of the passing in which we do what we do
You want to say like all we do is free videos on YouTube. That's it. But the passion in which we do free
You not gonna give people to do it the way we do it. That's given Hey, we're not getting paid no money
But we bring it in F look eight years. We've been bringing it
You got secret to success video to guru enviro you got our what's your wide at with viral? You got the st
Louis boy that went viral are you hearing me gracious is a party that went to all
It's for free what we do it with pass
so you're going to work with a attitude and you don't get it you so
Selfish that you can go with a attitude because you're not thinking about the people behind you the reason why you saying no to stuff
The reason why you pushing the snooze button the reason why are you still going to work?
trippin
The reason why you ain't blow up is because you still own 70% You still own 60%
You want to know why the world's passing you up?
Because whatever you do for a living you barely doing it you come and you don't want to be there
You're not bringing the fire. You're not bringing the passion
You're not bringing the heat and the reason why you're not bringing because you're thinking about you
You have not blown up because you're so self-centered
It's always about you you so conceited you're so arrogant. Your whole life is about you and that's why you haven't gone nowhere
But when you learn to think about somebody else how what you do affects how you're sleeping in the bed affects somebody else life
How you hitting the snooze button? It's affecting somebody else's life. How you being lazy?
She gotta walk past you to go to work you
Still own that your mama got to get up and go to work to provide for you
My mama worked for me I created a job
So what my mom finished working when she retired from where she didn't want to be she could not do what she liked to do
and get paid for
Come on, come on. Come on. I need you to finish this year up strong so I can get to real you in 2017
We tired of this retired us 60% you
Wee child is crying you just complaining you wee Tyler
This version greatness is in you you are here
You have been blessed by the created the building the earth you here leave your dog, Oh mark you
Here he bless you to be here do something
So whatever you got to do you do it
But I'm not about to compromise because you've inflicting pain and then those of you you were this close, but you compromised
You let your feelings get the best to you you compromised
You compromised you let your anger make you say something that you didn't really want to say
You let you let the fact that you was lonely you got lonely you did stuff that you know
You probably wouldn't do some of you have sold your greatness and your destiny for a couple dollars
And what I'm doing now, I was doing 20 years ago, and I have not been I didn't break
So what you don't understand why I'm doing what I'm doing
So what you don't see my greatness so that you don't understand how I do what I do. This is what I've been called to
And you let her live pain stopped you from your dream God it was there. He was running your business you were there
And your mama didn't like the fact that she was doing to your mama to understand and you let your mom in your ear
Like it was your mama's dream
You let your daddy talk you out of it
That was yours
That was something to creator gave to you that belong to you. My mother never understood, but she worked it for me now
I didn't quit
because people in understand I worked harder when people didn't support me we've never stopped I wake up every single day and I will
Prove to the world that I was here. I made my mark I was here and you can't take that away from me
I told you if I doubted dead you cannot take away the fact that Eric Thomas was here rule number 21 go into lying mode
If you're gonna do what you say, you're gonna do be what you say
You're gonna be you're gonna have to line me out that gizelle stop. I'm trying to tell you you were gizelle
You won't come up short. You were gizelle. You're not always going to get what you want out of life. You are gizelle
It's gonna be even have an average experience you a student. I need you in Lyon mode you a teacher
I need you in line mode. You will not reproduce. I need you in line mode. You try to lose weight Lyon mode
You can't do nothing significant in gazelle mode nothing
Nothing impressive happens in gazelle mode. Nothing happen when you run it
Nothing happening run mode give up mold quit mold scared mode fearful more nothing happens
Everything that happened in line mode like I'm coming to get you. I love y'all
I've see the one where the lioness is kind of sitting there and she
double-dutch it and all the Beast is running by and they just keep going and
She just in preparation mode and out of nowhere. There is no no music. No no preparation
You just see my man come out of nowhere and just boom Bob. Grab what fooled?
Boone ripped your heart out that's lion mode and you got to get to a place where you start executing somebody just help me out
last year the greatest news in the NBA
The greatest story in the NBA last year was what brightest story told in the NBA last year
Offseason was what Kevin Durant left go to Golden State
Durant like I'm out. I don't know where y'all come from but that hurt our because they supposed to be boys
Look at this picture for a minute because this way if you're gonna be successful
This is where I need you to go right here. What a pig
This was the one when you play your boy first game you and your homie was cool
Right, and this is where you emotionally cut it
This is when you cut my man this will you see my man? And he's trying to be cool
He trying to act like he leave you high and dry. He tried to act like the girls in the dreams
y'all have this the one where he clap it and you look my man in space and say you get it to me and that's
What most of you will never be successful?
Cuz there's some stuff in your past. You keep holding on key and you got to get to a point when you read it
Right and you ready to get to the next level he looking people used to be close to and say you dead to me
You did
42 triple doubles we shouldn't even be talking about the MVP
Ain't nobody else even if somehow make it close to the MVP the NBA is rigged and I'm through with him
Hey summer, many beginning a season come on. I'm to my high-octane
They said if he keep going at all season was laughing. They said he keep running him stuff like that
We're gonna burn out my man ain't burnt out
He don't look like any clothes to burn out
But you know why they said it cuz they can't operate in that level for that long home
So people were trying to put they limitations on you. I can I can do six gigs
I can do stuff we can leave here tonight. It would take me to a church. I give you another hour
You can't do it. Don't put your limitations on me. I'm dead to your limitation. No limitations don't
In my world. Those are your limitations keep them. Don't old watch them on TV
Go home, read the newspaper, but go home and look in the mirror go home
Call your homeboy and y'all talk about your lemon taste. I got nothing
I get off the plane from board to Dubai and get on the ground and I hit it
And some of y'all hold on the stuff you should be holding on to it should be dancing now
I'm gonna go do a funeral if you need to get rid of that junk like Barry you have you got to do
But it's weighing. You know, it's killing you every day you waking up thinking about it. You shouldn't be thinking about it
No more. It should be dead to you move on
And move towards your grave. I forget those things which are behind and I press I
Press toward the thing. I press I don't got time for that no more. It's not personal
I got nothing against you. I don't ain't you but I love me
Rule number 22. No you're amazing
Look, you don't even know what to do. If you don't know who you are
And so I want to tell you if nobody's told you perhaps your mom didn't tell you today
Perhaps your dad didn't tell you today
I don't know maybe he teach you how to attitude and she didn't say it before you left school, but you are
Amazing. Yep. I said it bring it in. I said it you are
Amazing. That's right. I'm gonna say it again you are
Amazing and you need to understand something. I do not get paid to do this. I've been doing this for eight years
I have no sponsors. I don't think somebody sent me like five dollars to do this. So et
Why would you keep doing it year after year?
Month after month week after week watch because I know something about you that you may not know about yourself you are
Amazing and it's time for you to act like you're amazing. It's time for you to do the amazing, right?
It's time for you to know you are amazing. So listen to me
I'm gonna give you an assignment, but before we go there I gotta let you know, I'm telling you the truth
I was a high school dropout when I was homeless right when I was getting kicked out of school
I'm just gonna keep it 100. I did not know I was amazing
I told you before no disrespect but my biological father won in my life
So I didn't have him to tell me when I got up every day et
You are amazing like me and my mom had some challenges. So my mom wouldn't necessarily telling me you are amazing
Right, and so I was eating out of trash cans right? Listen to me. I was getting kicked out of school
like I was in the mall stealing from the morgue giving trouble getting arrested listen and some
Pastor brought me to church right and I'm telling you my man would tell me on a weekly basis you are
Amazing and it's time for you to act amazing and do the amazing
So I wanted to say this to you real quick. You are not your test score. Are you hear me? Look et
I've never done well on a standardized test you are not your grades
You are amazing you you're not what happened to you where you were born?
What circumstance you come from? You are amazing you hear me?
You are amazing and the day you recognize you're amazing the day you understand how amazing you are
Everything changed and I said if they didn't change my test scores didn't change my grades didn't necessarily change like that
like I miss when I became aware the fact that I'm gifted that I'm
Special and I need you to understand something when you recognize who you are when you when you realize how amazing you are
There's certain things. You're not gonna do no more when you recognize how amazing you are. There's certain people. You're not gonna hang around
No more when you realize how amazing you are. There's just certain things. You're not gonna do no more
Because Eagles and pigeons don't run together and when you realize sweetheart
That's you an eagle my brother when you realize you were King my sister when you realize you're Queen
Things are gonna change why cuz Queens don't do what everybody else do Kings
Don't do what everybody else do and so I'm telling you you are amazing
Now drawing me a line and I want you to do me a favor. That's right
I said it draw a line and I just want you to put one thing on there look matter of fact two things put
amazing and put SuperDuper amazing and I just want you to write down all the things that make
Like we're just sit down. I don't care about your teacher
We're talking about your grades right now not talking about what you did in school what you didn't do in school
You're not talk about where you were born where you come from. We're not talking about that. Look look. Look. Oh all that aside
I just want you to write down. I'm amazing why I'm a beautiful person. I'm amazing. I'm intelligent in my own right? I'm amazing
I'm an artist. I'm amazing. I do music. I'm amazing. I love people like whatever. I don't know what it is
I'm amazing heat deep everything that makes you special
everything that makes you you
That I want you to get up. Listen to me. I love you guys
That's why I do what I do not time for you to recognize how amazing you were right, so just do that for me
Just write down how amazing you are
I just want you to look at in the morning look at it at night look at it in the evening
I'm not telling you something I read in a book or something. Somebody told me
I'm telling you I went from being who I was to Who I am now
Guess what my biological father never came back in my life
Like I'm being 100 like nothing changed
But I woke up one day and realized yo e so what your father wasn't in your life. You're still amazing
So what you got kicked out of Detroit Public School, it's still amazing
So what you ate out of trash can it's still amazing and there's nothing your circumstances could do about it
It's sort of different between the oeg and the new et. Is that I know by the grace of God. I'm amazing
You were amazing - so I need you to do me a favor. You start acting like it
It's your boy et saying I love you
I believe in you and now it's time for you to believe in yourself rule number 23 commit to greatness
Now a lot of young people are the black mamba the Black Mamba
Let me tell you something when you talk about the black mamba you talk about practice
It's a must have I watch this dude lose a game a game. I don't even know if it was the playoffs
I think it was like a regular game against the Miami Heat in Miami, South Beach, Florida
I don't know if you ever been there before but it's you want to go
It's a nice place to just hang out
Especially if you on the road playing ball, it's a nice place after the game to go get dinner sit on the beach
It's the night and I'm sure of you in ba. They've probably got a VIP section for them on the beach
And unfortunately
The Lakers lost to the Miami Heat because Black Mamba missed the wide-open shot in the corner set shot in miss knew
what he did for the next 3-4 hours why everybody was getting dressed and going on the beach he sat there for
Hours shooting the exact same shot over and over and over and over like here number one championship
I'd like now hold up where everybody else at for the Lakers
They need to be out there as a squad like up but the Black Mamba is out there doing this thing
Like I'm not on them I messed up I got to practice and this is not a coach practice
This is not an organism or the organization in Carles worth
This was just flat-out the Black Mamba was saying this is a must have and where most of you go wrong
you're not even 4.0 and you not studying like you're not even a
4.0 student
like you got a two point A to five a three something and you still not really study it like that because for you it's
Like eyes not a must-have
It blows my mind I worked with professional athletes I work with d1 athletes all over the world
And when I look at Twitter and Instagram, it blows my mind how dudes on Instagram
I'm like Ron you have not won a championship
Like that's what you come here for to win a championship
And so if you don't win a championship, I don't even know why it's people Pro
I don't even know how you have enough time to do a 30-second video you bro
How did you have time to do a video?
How did you have time like to do a dance routine when you should be practicing you should be lifting weights
You should be looking at film
You said not me that you want to win the tourney?
That you want to win at all you want to go to the Final Four?
How do you want to go to the Final Four, but your schedule don't look like the Final Four?
What are you tweeting about when you wrote?
Rule number 24 don't be average now. Listen what I want to talk to you night about is don't be average
Don't be average
Average people make a certain amount of money average people live a certain type of lifestyle and I'm not disrespecting average people
I'm just saying if you have a choice, don't be a verage because in life when you roll the dice worst case scenario
You're gonna land
So don't be average because if you don't try you will get to average
Right. So let's not shoot for every because average is gonna be there. So I need you to be what what's the P word?
I need to be what come o I need you to be what?
And I don't need you to be nothing else when you do your job you do it in a way where note that you cannot
Get fired talking to my wife to dislike. I want you to clean up
I'm like we bout to get into it's like one split
I'm like how because I know you wanted a different way than I do it I clean a bitch
I'm just being real I clean after so when you say clean you have to break that down because I know with my cleaning yo
Clean, it's two different links
No, I'm trying to help you. It's two different clean. My wife say you don't clean you shit
So you take stuff from one area and you put another in that area clean with another area
When I clean you don't see nothing. Everything's gone some of you when you get a job you shift you don't clean
So I need you to find out what productive is when you get to that
Internship you get that job you get in that relationship with that female that male whatever you do
I need you to find out what for done not what you think product of you find out what's really productive you do that and
You ain't going they can't get rid of rule number 25 don't dismiss your haters
Anybody got any haters in the building see em real quick God and your haters in the bill
Let me just see your hand real quick good right some of them down right just right and anger to God
I just said get it out your system. All right, let's get it out just said look people will hate on you
It's okay. As a matter of fact, I told y'all this before like do me a favor
Do not dismiss your haters because sometimes iron sharpens iron
Like sometimes you need to look pressure to get to that next level. So do me a favor
Don't just miss your haters some of the stuff they say is true. I don't just miss all of it
So I'm gonna stuff your haters say it's true. Let me tell you something
Some of your haters are gonna give you a perspective that your mama not gonna give you that your mama
She don't always tell you this
For most of y'all mamas now some of us have different models
But most of our mamas they're gonna tell us that like mama
How am I gonna do that with I'm saying most marvelous? They just gonna you know, baby, you're right
They're not gonna really chest on you. So you need your haters because your haters are gonna point out stuff, right?
So we're not going to dismiss our haters altogether. We're gonna listen to them. We're gonna hear what they're saying
We're gonna make sure that their perspective is not
Their perspective is wrong or right and we take the stuff that we can take the stuff that we can't use don't worry about it
rule number 26 set strong goals
I got an older white male keep probably in his sixties maybe right and my man says to me, you know
Like I heard what you say et. But how do you sustain it? I'm like, okay
I'm like I said, he'll only make sure I'm hearing what you're saying. He like you talk about
120 you talk about going harm you talk about having what you want being what you want. Do what you want
Okay, I get it. But how do you sustain it? I'm thinking is there real question? I said listen to me very closely
How did that start this whole presentation off?
He said write down the people name that you love I said, duh, if you waking up every day and think about your wife
No, how do you not sustain it if you wake up every day and you're looking at your son?
How do you not sustain it? You think I'm gonna put my kid's life in a hand some other man
do you think that's my role as a father just
Think my role is to allow my kids
to come here and pay all this money go to school and do everything they did and now they gotta go beg somebody else for
A job that's not my role or responsibility
To sustain it. What do you mean?
How do you not sustain I ask you why are you not pumped up?
Why you have days up I'm asking you why you get 70% you'll love nobody
Is there not somebody that you don't love more than yourself
Is there's not somebody you waking up for is it not somebody who's grinding for?
Somebody told me that they get distracted easy when you tense up the reason why you didn't distract me because you're not eight and nineteen
You wake up to every single dance
I gotta go deep many of you are getting these tracks here because you don't have something that's stronger than the fact
You need something stronger than the distraction you
Getting distracted with party you get distracted with spoken you get distracted with drinking you getting distracted with sleeping you getting distracted with video games
Wow because the video game is stronger than your goal
So my homies all the time bro didn't got to do it. Y'all be playing. I'm like forget about the money
You're just singing it. I'm for real. Probably blowing me off
Rule number 27 be driven to succeed. I want your Red Box about two months ago. I went to go
Give me a red box. I told see I was getting a red box and he joking you still getting ready Bob
I'm like, yeah, it was one red box
He's like Netflix. You ain't no Netflix. I'm like no, I wanna watch TV. Oh, I saw one watch no movie
I'm a little small computer a little small computer put it on TV and say I can put my stuff on TV
I'm gonna find one no auxiliary cord all running through my crib like that. He's like not a smart TV, bro
I'm hearing hey, I ain't got no Smart TV. I
Need you to hear what I just said. I got bread and I got the same TV
I bought when I'm gonna get out why cuz I could put on and that jump and come on y'all laugh you like
Why would you do a TV like that? Cuz I remember back in the day
We used to get the hangar with the aluminum foil and drop that Joker
Oh and this cloudy cloudy and you tryin to do what you gotta do. So what I got is ways
We used to have to this old school you had the turn to get the stage station to?
Then your two to seven
Right and that joint went off that night y'all team?
You don't even go on our TV like he left the whole egg on you see by the dawn's early light
then your TV go I
Could just go and catch me. I'll get a brand new one
But the reason why I don't do it is because of a healthy sense of scarcity is great
You get too much. You got too much. You get everything you lose your bites. I can't afford to leave my fight cuz another
And if they do it better than you might anyone had a life battery
My wife is retired at 45 cuz she got hit man. She cannot go back to work. I cannot let you beat me
So I'm not gonna go five three four columns
Scarcity you cannot have everything you see it's not healthy. There's a stencil. There's a part of lack that make you hungry
There's a plant eating peanut butter and jelly sandwiches that make you deeper than to do. There's eating five-star meal
Let me tell you something man. I promise me or everything I love
if I could do my life all over again, I promise I would I'm glad my dad I
Swear I'm glad I lived in a band of dude. I
Swear to you, I'm glad I got my period I would be way smarter
Looking at growing me and where they want to be in life and no part of they like and they waking up at eight and
Nine o'clock in the moon. I'm like bro what you're smoking. I
Thought you was a Christian you want no, no drugs. No drugs. Are you invested in you? Do you care about you?
So what you need to transition from which are entitled self what you need to transition from is friends and fun
You need to stop having it and till you get to where you want to be in life
You need to stop having all that fun and you need to just start making up in your mind. Just start saying you broke
Just start saying it because you probably are thrilled. Even if you got some money you probably got your parents stuff
It probably don't belong you which means you didn't earn it is what I'm talking about
So if you have something that you did not earn you have to stop telling yourself that you have
Something look you got to hear what I'm telling you. I'm trying to help you
I only take pictures of clothes that belong to me. I
Don't put my boys shoes on and then take a pic in it like their minds
Know and what I'm trying to tell you is you are broke
But you don't realize you broke because you're living somebody else's life
And if you're living somebody else's life
What you should be able to do is say I am grateful that this person is trying to set me up for greatness
But I won't fake it like it's my life
All I'm saying to you is when you act like you've got something that you really don't
Then you don't have the drive that it takes to be successful rule number 28 make a decision. Okay make a difference
Until you make a decision
You better hear what I'm telling you man, I'm talking about the secret to success
I'm always telling you how I went from one spot to the next spot and that was hit right there
Listen to me catch the first principle. You got it here. You can't make a difference until you make a decision
So for real some of you men you keep crying you complain about your job you complain about where you are financially
You complain about your relationships you complain about your opportunities you complaining complaining?
Complaining listen to me you murmuring and complaining you complaining and complaining it could put shut up
Stop complaining and do me a favor if you want to make a difference
All you got to do is one thing this side you can start it
You want some different listen to me. All you got to do is make a decision. That's it
And for those of you will be making the wrong decision
All you got to do is make the right decision. But if you want to make a difference make a decision
Are you hearing what I'm telling you?
What I'm trying to do for you to take you to that next level is I'm trying to give you control of your life back
Some of you you ain't got control you talking about your job
You got control listen to me. Some of you talk about your economics like you ain't got no control
You got a control?
I want you to know that your life right now the sum total of your decisions, not your mama decisions
Not your daddy listen to me
Even if you made a decision you decided to make their decisions, so I need you to me a favor
I need you from this day forward for the rest of your life make a
Decision and I talked about again something that I've read. I'm telling you what I experienced. I remember being upset
Okay, the word is pissed off. Forgive me. When the boss go tell me. I can't go see my daughter get her award
You heard me say it before it burned it burns. She goes
You can't go sit my daughters getting an academic award
Seven eight years old ain't nothing like having your daddy in the building and my boss telling me I can't go. So guess what?
I let it burn and then one day I made a decision and I made a decision to walk away
And let me tell you something. I walked away and two weeks later. The video went viral
When you want to succeed as bad as you want to breathe with vibro
But it didn't go viral a job made a decision the video never went viral when I was complaining
He never went by when I was Merman
It never went viral when I was talking just to be talking but when I made a decision to walk away
when I made a decision I
When I made a decision to follow my destiny, I felt it calling me
My destiny was calling me and when I decided to stop letting it call me
But I chased after her we went viral make a decision rule number 29
energize
you give
70% effort the most the optimal that can come out of giving 70% energy as what
70% outcomes, that's it. So y'all got do me a favor career. I'm not playing like the energy y'all give off the subs
Like it ain't no other way for me to say it sucks and I don't care about the energy you giving me right now
But if you're taking this energy you giving me into the real world you gonna be average so when you get out of here
I'm come on I need energy
You don't have to be the smartest person in the world, but sometimes when you're smart people still don't notice you
People always notice what
Always if you're not careful, you'll get electrocuted
You have to pay attention to energy and things that energize
That's all I'm asking you to do
I'm saying most of you are not successful not because you have reached your highest level of success
You are not successful because you stopped focusing on it
You quit focus on you got a job and he just stopped rule number 30 find an accountability partner
All right. Y'all guys do me a huge favor. All right. Look, I know. I know the power one
Trust me, look don't get too analytical
I know the power of one, but I'm telling you sometimes to make a milestone become a reality
You got to get it done by twos one of the greatest basketball players that ever played the game. Yep, Mike with joy
I
Sure, didn't do it alone. Come on. Oh
You got when you say Mike, you gotta say Scottie Pippen. Are you hear me?
La la baby when you say Kobe Bryant like real for real you you can't go without saying when you talk about that era
You can't go without saying shaky low kneel are you hearing me? Sometimes you up? The power one is great
MJ was doing his thing on the solo. Yup
Kobe was doing his thing on the solo, but you got to keep it 100 when Jordan had Scottie. Ah
magical
Magic happen Oh Shaq was with Kobe. Ah
magic
Happen and what I'm telling you is as long as I was doing it by myself
Yeah, as long as I was doing it by myself
I could never get that dissertation done the power of
To know man, and I mean it no man is an island
And let me tell you what changed the game would change the game is when I met with dr
June what changed the game is when I sat down with dr. June and I had some accountability. Can I say?
Accountability partner your problem is you're doing it by yourself
your problem is you don't want nobody to know that you got I know I know you're afraid for them to see your
Weaknesses. I know you're afraid to be vulnerable
Yup, you're afraid to tell them your dream. You look you got to tell somebody
Somebody got to hold you accountable
I'm not telling you to tell the world but one other person needs to know and one other person needs to hold you accountable
And my life changed
My milestone became a reality
Listen to me. I'm giving you the secret to success today. I told dr. June. I want to get it done. And dr
Jewel looked me in my face and said don't play with me. Don't play with me. Are you ready?
Look, not only do I have a PhD
Not only about sat on many committees. Listen to me very closely
I can and will help you to get through this but don't play with me
You got to be serious and Doc said all I need you to do you tell you tell me you tell me when you want
This PhD you tell me when you we finish with this dissertation
You tell me when you jump and I'll tell you how how I'll show you what you have to do every single day
How many are pages you have to write how much research I do how much time you have to spend on it?
Listen to me. It did not become a reality. It didn't become real into our sat down with dr. Jr
We made a commitment. Are you hearing me before it was just an idea?
before it was just a thought before was just something I said, but when I sat down a mile or in my know
Some an Elan OE motto man the man when I sat down
And I made that commitment and I shook his hand
When I looked him in his eyes and said I'm ready to get it done. All we did was meet every Monday
Are you hearing me? I know this sounds too simple. I know it sounds too good to be true
All we did was sit down on Mondays at nine o'clock and every single week
He said this is what you need to get done
If you are a man and you do what you said you gonna do and you make no excuses
And you don't let nothing get in your way
I
Guarantee you in a year's time if that's how long you want this process to take I guarantee you we can get it done
What I can't do is I can't do it for you
But I can show you what it takes to me and I didn't want there was a part of me that I never really wanted
To link up with nobody else because I really didn't want to fully expose myself
I didn't really he said to me kid. You've never written a dissertation before how would you know how to do it?
That's what I'm here for
and when you get that life coach
That's the problem with some of you you can't get to that next level because you're trying to do it on your own you're trying
To do it in your own strength
and I'm not saying there's no power and one mic was murdering the game putting up 60 something against a
Boston mic was dunk contest mic was doing it but might never reach those milestones by himself
He had to bring somebody else into his sphere of influence
Rule number 31 my personal favorite believe I am
Come on, I am
Well, I am an entrepreneur
yeah, you could clap if you want you I am I
am come on, I will never search for well, I will be cured for I am I
am an entrepreneur
Listen to melisten open and open and open up I am well therefore I will not search for what I already am I?
Will not search for what's already inside of me. I am success. I
can I will I
Must break all barriers on my way Shh on my journey to wealth in success
I must break all barriers. Not most not
Most all barriers everything that's before my mama
my daddy all barriers my past I am I
Am the greatest that has ever done this not because I'm comparing myself to them, but ain't nobody like me
I am and your problem is you hadn't got to the I am yes
You hadn't even bought into it. And what I want to do before you leave is buying to 120% That's why you follow me
That's why you watch me because when I get up and talk
It's 120 percent when I talk you don't feel like he might not believe what he's saying
You know it you don't listen to me in the morning when you on that treadmill
Because you think I kind of think I know what I'm talking about
You are a hundred percent clear. Like yo E. He got some confidence like he walking with another spirit like he owns something different
What is he are?
I woke up one day when America said I can't wear a hat and shoes and I just had to say I am
You're trying to get information. First you reading books you haven't convinced you that you should be doing this
You haven't convinced you that you need to put the money here so you could get where you're trying to get to you don't believe
that you are and the very first thing that creator said was tell them I am rule number 30 to
Surround yourself with the greats. I gotta take y'all back somebody showing real quick lying and gizelle. Rah
Right. Y'all know I'm on that line a gazelle boy
The line is the king of the jungle, but I gotta be honest with you guys
I got to tell you the truth
Right and that's allottee the Tigers should be kept the Tigers should be this is gonna juggle dog
I'm just gonna break down how I got to where I am and how I'm about to get to where I want to go
So the tiger Ichi, what do you mean by that?
Well, do your homework in terms of pound for pound a mono e mono the tiger is ferocious
The tiger can take out the lion now go back and look at the tiger. I'm talking about it structurally massive
Well, you look at a tiger you don't see nothing, but I'm talking about muscle. That's all you see
I'm talking about muscle, but guess what even though a tiger probably could be the lion 101 these mano-a-mano
You know what? The problem is. The reason why the lion is a king of the jungle is not because I'm stronger
He's he's the king of the jungle if there's some problem
What's this Tigers run a loan and even though they're ferocious. They don't run in a pride
They're by themselves, right? And that's some of you right now you sweet
I'm not gonna lie you sweet
But you will be your same sweet for the rest of your life because you're by yourself you are alone
You're not with a prime. That's the problem with some of you you a tiger you a tiger all day
We not debate not sweet you are we're not debating how skilled you are
We're not debating you the one but the problem is you run a loan
Right, you do everything by yourself. You do everything alone. And you you're only as strong as you can be by yourself
Look, I'm on that Voltron boy
I'm going that vote on board that when we come together we can do more together than I can do along
All right shit boy easy
Come on
Say it ain't gonna be easy to do it until you do but you have what it takes just surround yourself with other great
To get in a community where you're not the best of the best, but they get in the community where other people can stretch you
Save you and support you right and lift you up rule number 33
Discipline yourself as I was like yo, you got to discipline yourself. I started looking at mother Teresa of
Gandhi and I was like yo, bro. Gandhi would go fast from sex and he was married
He were fast from talking
You know, I just started watching these great peoples like all these people fast and not about fast and not the piece
but they were very
Discipline people and they would not allow their exterior world to dominate or destroy their internal world
I just like you I want to get to a place where I can control me. My family members have grown
I lost two uncle cirrhosis of the liver brilliant man, but just drinking drinking drinking and I was like yo
I do not want to my father was a substance abuser for years
I was like, yo, I don't want a life where something else is controlling me, you know
Like for real when I left home and said I don't want to be controlled no more
Like I meant that like, I don't know nothing to control me, but me and so I gotta put myself under extreme
Discipline to make sure I'm free. So when people see me you get up at 3:00. You don't drink you don't smoke
I'm not doing that because I think I'm better. No BIOS. Oh, I think you're gonna go to hell because you had a drink I
Just want I want to control I want freedom and for me disciplining myself
means more freedom and unless I you discipline yourself people who I
Told my son other dads like your son. I do not want you to have fun
I just seen a history of people who just have fun Christmas
Thanksgiving Halloween no
There are the people that night
Every night the other people who end up in a 20s having a great deal of fun
What in a 40s and 50s they were working for somebody?
And I'm not saying nothing wrong with cleaning toilets
But they doing something they don't want to do for the rest of their life and they can't retire they played so much
You know, so for me
I just look at Venus in Sarina Michael Jackson when he used to like five and six just dancing all night
I just think the more man discipline himself the greater
You don't mean it's gonna happen
But the greater the probability that he has this sense of freedom rule number 34 find your inner drive
What makes Brady want to win a fifth? What makes joy 39 39. What makes Jordan say, okay
I got four like it's not even a new season. He said we go back. We got to pick one
what makes Sarina get 23 and still going like what makes
Venus who was sick and should have been gone and I she's 36 years old
What makes her fight to get to the Australian Open and I'm telling you it's it's not the money the network
It's not you know, the vision board. It's I believe for those of us who were where we are
It's something within you know, and and you can't go by that
You know something I can't give it to you Luis care like you've got to go within and find that and pull that stuff out
Rule number 35 have wild thoughts. This is what I want y'all to do tonight tonight
I want to go I want to go somewhere because I told you you know
like I don't know if you maybe because you're a human and
You've gotten so accustomed to human that maybe you don't know what you're capable of doing as a human, right?
Anybody get a new phone when you get a new phone?
But the iPhone 7 8 right the iPhone or you went to the galaxy when you get that a Christmas or you get that gadget
When you first open up that gadget, what are you what are you happy about?
What it can do all the stuff it can do
Right if you like a geek, I'm not a geek right, but I imagine the view of geek you're going through life
I only use the stuff I need like I know every bitch's thing and the other stuff, right?
But the geeks know everything you can do. Let's do me very closely
I believe that some of us have gotten so caught up with school and work
you forgot what you can do as a human like right you just forgot like you so caught up on life and
Problems. You're so caught up on paying bills you forgot
You human you forgot you the one made up the phone you made up the TV you've made up cars you made up fly
I got humid with wine a hundred years ago
They would have told me I could like we can fly to Australia and watch TV you watch a TV
Oh, we watch a TV on the way to Australia
This is this is what happens when you add wild thoughts and that's what what's all about tonight
like wild thoughts
Like wild thoughts like like I don't want you to be in school
for grades because I told y'all we think we passed that and that's why school is so hard for some of you that's why I
Like it so hard for some of you because that's all you doing his life
Are you having a wild thought school more? You don't dream crazy no more
You kind of settled into like whatever little life they gave you whatever a check they gave you whatever they told you to do for
40 hours like you like getting on that and I just want you to do yourself a favor
Maybe the weekend when you're not busy. I just want you to start touching the buttons and see what you came up warm
I want you to get out of the average thinking
And look, okay. I'm gonna get your secret
I want you to start having
wild thoughts because here's the deal if you have wild thoughts and they don't work out you can always go back to average thoughts the
Whole bunch of people waiting for you when you come back. I promise you they wait you good average is gonna be there
So just do me a favor, but just start thinking crazy. And wild I want to own multiple homes and multiple cars
I want to have that nonprofit. I want out of that profit and I'm gonna be able to travel the world. I'm gonna whatever
Okay, raise your hands. I'm telling the truth. You are crazy stupid talented. You know you are
But you get stuck on average not using your for particular
Yeah, just some stuff, you know you could be doing this
You ain't doing them you CA, you know you could be doing hands out. Let's do me real quick Eric Thomas
I don't really know who I am, but you here tonight, right?
So I'm telling you I'm giving you full permission to start to have a wildest dream to be yourself. I'm giving you permission
It's not waiting on people
It's the weirdest thing
I mean some of the most talented smartest people in the world who stuff because they waiting for it
I gave you permission. I give you permission to be yourself
like I'm give me and why why do I have the authority cuz I'm myself I
Feel I'm in full erik tiemens permission. I ask no other motivational speaker
Was it alright to go hit by I'm just doing what I know. I've been called a dude
unapologetically, I
Wanna make sure I say that I ain't even know if I can say it
I just try to see if I can say it. I was in my head. I was like, can I say that word?
I just said it and came out. You don't have to apologize to anybody to be great you
Don't owe it to anybody else to play little no more. Come on. Don't play little no more
You don't want your brother to feel bad or you don't want your cousin - look you have full permission
You don't want your parents to think you will know it all you have full permission to be your greatness right now
You have full permission to be your greatness
Whoever you whatever your greatness is you have full permission to be that right this second rule number 36 focus on your losses
So I need y'all. Do me a favor for real. Listen to me very closely
I'm gonna show you how to be successful
You have to understand that your losses and that's why I want you to look at them every day
Because your losses fuel you in a way and then wait at you're winning can never feel you. Well, you take an L
You take it you take the right air you like I'm gonna be very cautious on that next move I make if you're smart
So number one every single day. I want you to go to bed at night
Stop playing games and be honest about the wins and the losses. So I always remember where I came from
I remember all the arrows I took because when you forget the arrows, that's when you like you big and bad
I remember those are the ones man. Those are the ones that humble me
Those are the ones that when I get on stage and it's ten thousand people and I think about what I did to my mom
and my
Father who raised me I think about the hard disappointed myself
I think about disappointing my wife I think about disappointing my kids like I got a story with my daughter
where you know I'm saying I discipline my daughter about three years ago and
I don't know that I wish I could get it back
but I wish I could get the
Experience back cuz it because it was one of those things where four years so you could tell she was like yo
I can't believe you. I was just like man. I was a loss for me and it took us a while to repair our relationship
I took a pause
So when I think about those losses and humbles me and I can't be like floating with the smoke at the event it upset
Smoke at the event the music is playing and they do miss the coming from lunch in, Michigan
Motivation speaker in the world
I don't run out like I run out like and I hope me and my daughter could get on don't kill us
Hope she'll take that heat our relationship with Arthur and me and my son man. I should've okay
You let yourself out but I'm one of those days I were on stage with the losses
I'm trying to help somebody out. You wonder why you can't get to the next level
You're not helpful enough to get to the next level you focus on your win and not your losses
I need you to switch that rule number 37 take small steps small steps
Great distances. You heard what I said
I'm going to say it slower
Because I need you to embrace it and fill it and this is about to take us to a hold of the level y'all
Look, I'm gonna say it again. I'm gonna say it slow
This year ha ha this year we're gonna take small steps
But we will eventually get great distances small steps great distances
Are you hearing what I'm telling you small steps great distances, so I'm gonna give you four principles for the next 90 days
That's what we own for the next 90 days. Listen to me principle. Number one. We're gonna start with the miniscule
Are you hear me? Put my steps up there car put my steps up. I need them to see them
We're gonna literally do small steps together, right?
So every day get your Fitbit
Get your phone and we're literally going to take steps together small steps
Not big steps and then I'm gonna keep my phone with me
And as I travel to the world, I'm gonna give you principles throughout the week so we can make it happen minuscule first
All right, that that's that's the stuff you do. It's small small steps step step
We're going to do together that you not even go. Nobody's going you go do some stuff with your boy et
Nobody's even gonna know you're doing it right but that's what we're gonna start. That's like the GED right miniscule
No, I didn't have a graduation
I'll even watch across the stage a whole lot of people didn't come and see your boy when I got them GED
GD was something they put in the mail and he came to my crib, right?
We didn't do no celebration, but it was that miniscule
It was that small thing that I did that eventually kept your boy et in the game
All right, then mediocre, right?
That's like below average that didn't even D me getting to college took me 12 years to get a four-year degree
Mediocre guys that wouldn't even average like 12 years that ain't even average but that 12 years
Getting that getting that degree in 12 here. Still kept me in the game. Yeah. Yep and didn't immeasurable. Yep
That's the stuff you should be doing right then. Yep, then I got the master's degree. Yup, the measurable
We're gonna work on the measurable. We take it on top minuscule
Mediocre we some of you are trying to go straight to measurable straight off the cup and then we go in the miracle
We're gonna get the miracle territory baby. That's the PhD. That's the book that's via number
One of the number one motivational speakers in the world. And where did it start it started with the miniscule
So you doing too much you're doing absolutely too much and we're gonna take our time small steps small steps
great distances rule number 38 holds your own weight
I need you to be honest do an honest assessment
and I want you to write down what it is you're trying to do and I need you to be very
Honest about where you are in terms of what you're trying to do. Like, where are you?
So for those of you who like I want to be a millionaire
I just need you to really be like think through where are you financially?
Like in terms of financial literacy, where are you in terms of financial discipline? Where are you and in your past?
Where are you? Do you spend money? You don't have
So I heard somebody said he said today I thought it was fun
Right, somebody was talking about and at this time time, I'm in tally. I need y'all to hear me
Can you can you lift your own weight? Right? Can you lift your own weight?
So somebody would say like yo
I don't know why y'all on the phone all
Proud of the fact that you could change your own oil like why would you want to change your oil anywhere?
That's not your job. Right and somebody was like, well, I saved 140 dollars
He likes saved 140 dollars, but what have you make 250 dollars in an hour? No hear what I'm saying?
Why would you change your own oil to save 140 dollars when it took you three hours to do it?
And somebody like yo, so you said you always I said look
Let me jump in like I ain't trying to be disrespectful. But first of all, I didn't go to school to change oil
That ain't my job that's somebody's job let my man do his job
Somebody else said that when he changed your oil because he went to school
There's some other stuff under the engine that he's see that you don't see when you change the oil
So why you saved a hundred and forty dollars?
You missed something else that he would have helped you catch so that the life of your car
So you changed your oil but you didn't notice the three or four of the things that was missing
I said look, let's not talk about you saving 140. Here's the challenge. You can't pull your own weight
The challenge is you shouldn't have a car that costs you a hundred and forty dollars to change the oil
When you ain't got a husband four thousand change the oil
You should have that car in the first place
Why do you have a vehicle that the oil costs 140 and you can't afford it
Why would you buy something that you got to change the oil that's not your job and you know?
Why you doing it because it's no longer a car to you - a status symbol
And so we're dealing with something deeper. You can't hold your own way
You bought something you can't afford why the deeper issue is because you got a self-esteem problem
And
So you got shortcuts
So you drive a car to make it look like you somewhere you are
But when you actually there you ain't gotta have a car that look like you there because you there
No hear what I just said when you're there you don't have to look like you there cuz you there
But when you're not there
You can't pick your own weight up you have to do stuff and now you didn't messed up your whole
Credit because you bought a car so that people can think in somewhere that you not and you've destroyed your whole future
That if you could hold your own way
You could drive around the Ford Fusion and be some tombow come like like a ranger you getting out that joint like a Range Rover
You getting out the for fusion like what like you in a 7:45 a lot like what
Wow because you ready are you here, are you ready rule number 39 be you be true to yourself
You know, you know especially being in
LA, you know, it's so superficial, you know, some people can be so superficial, you know, there's no debt, you know
it's so dense, you know and so I would say
You know to your own self be true
Find out who you are what your gift is what you love like eat what you like to eat go or you like to go?
Like be you you'll find out that when you're you you will attract you, you know
You will attract all that happiness the wealth that you can buy being you but if you're fake, you know
You can't do it rule number 40 push your way to success
Let's go to this last one real quick. I got a message from a kid today. I want you to read it
AET is what he texted me. How do you have you balance pooling and stay with a routine?
You came to my school ivory listen to your speech, but I'm struggling in school and working at the same time
I have to stay working to pay bills. I go to tutoring. I hold a lot of scholarships that I have to maintain therefore
It's usually it means meetings and extra curriculum stuff. I'm struggling there. So he asked me et. What should I do?
I said what year are you telling me Junior? I got a year and a half to go. I said keep struggling
What you want me to tell you
What you want me to tell you stop quit give up, okay
Well, the next week said yeah, I had a meltdown in class. My sister pulled me to the side
I say you might have a couple more before success. It's the part of the game
you can't be successful without some meltdown struggle for another year and a half and be free for the rest of your life or
You can say I'm tired of struggling and stop struggle and struggle for the next 20 30 years, press past it
Come on, Press Pass. Stop whining and crying - give it up. Press past it. It's going to hurt. Yes
Ask any mother has had a child. It's probably feel like they gonna die
But guess what they get through it and on the other side when that child comes out, they forget all about the bank
No dream count on you and my buddy no cookies an iceberg push
It's a lie. It's inside
How do you know you feel it you dream about it?
You eat and sleep and every day when people talk to you tell them just rubble do so push just push Master fight push
Don't quit. Don't get push
Can you push your way to success you push yourself to that 4.0? You push yourself to that scholarship?
You push yourself to the next level rule number 41 pay the fare the transitions going to be hard
I'm not gonna lie to you go from being on the block
going to be a high school dropout to getting a GED is not the
transition is not easy in order for you to go for running level to the next level in order for any woman to
Transition for any man to transition the thing that they want must be greater than the thing
they currently have
you only go to another level when you roll when you own this level and you eat not a trash cans and you say
enough is enough when you live in an abandoned buildings in the winter, and you say enough you only
transition from one level to the next
when you tie to the level you own you keep telling me this happened in your life and that's happened in your life and it
Who is happening to everybody?
You let your pain Punk you you let your pain make you quit you thinking special
You think you the only woman we all go through?
I'm just gonna give some out of mine so you don't have to go through it. Just like everybody else
You gonna have to pay to fit sweat blood?
tears
But guess what when you walk across that stage
It's gonna have that much more meaningful rule number 42 work on your focus work on your focus
We're going your focus perspective is everything
Let me tell you something
The problem with most of you is that you see
Difficult as something negative for real for real you and I want you to I want you to see difficult differently
Are you hearing me? I need you to see
Difficult differently now now that weight lifter when my man looking at those weights when he got that iron that iron is heavy
But he's not looking at that. I like look how heavy the iron is and he knows what its gonna do
It's gonna tear his muscles to pieces he gets it but what he understands he if he tears them down
They go rebuild themselves and when they rebuild themselves, they're that much stronger
Listen to me the more you go through the more difficult. It is the more challenging
It is listen to me the harder it is. Are you hearing me the more challenging?
It is all you're doing baby is building my soul. You're building muscle, so don't quit
Don't give up don't don't stare at them you listen to me. You don't get bumped by staring at weights
you don't get bumped by by look you don't get healthier by staring at it you get healthier by running up to it and
Grabbing it and pushing it look push through that stuff push through it
You can get through it and sadi won't put on you more than you can bear
You can get through it rule number 43 live what you're talking about
You want to get your credit up and whatever you're doing
You know I'm saying I think Shawn if you and I both sat here and talked about health
You'd blow me out the water. You know I'm saying and not just the information
But you've been doing it in terms of the physical working out for years
You also had an illness that you know that you studied. It was like I gotta get through this
You know you you you actually helped thousands and thousands and thousands of people do it
So there's a credibility that you have because you you become one with the with with what you're doing
whereas somebody who read a book and then say it it's like ah
That's good information. But some kind of way it's not coming across the right way
so I think the first thing you need to do is like literally live what you're talking about and I think a lot of people
You know, like I hear people shine, you know how to make a million dollars. I'm like, were you you and Dad?
What hit me how to make a million dollars like what does that mean? Like you're making that up?
You don't really believe that you know
Or you haven't lived it rule number 44 find your fuel and I think when I started dating didi
That was the first time in my life
It was like yo, whew, wow those fuels like here's this girl and it's saying like yo, I got dreams and ghosts really?
You know
She was the one with the dreams and go always
Always went to school did what she's for the goody two-shoes went to school doing she was supposed to she's the only child
It was just her and her mom, you know, she's very focused and she was kind of like oh I like you
I'd like to have a future with you
But if we're gonna have a future together, like I can't I can't date a high school dropout, you know
Like I can't be with somebody so she decided she got accepted into college
I'm going to college if you don't get your GED and follow me like it's a wrap so imagine man
We are sixteen seventeen sitting on the curb. I'm homeless high school dropout
Imagine being with this young lady and you're dreaming and she's talking about when we get older with my kids
We don't live in this house and I'm gonna be a nurse you doing whatever and so for me
I was the first time in my life
That it was like y'all go whew, like, you know, I could be something I could do something
So hear that for me that was and it was like yo, your dad is a high school dropout
Your grandfather was hot and then no disrespect cuz my father and I have a relationship now
So I you know I'm saying no disrespect to him, but he dropped out he had kids by different, you know
My grandfather didn't finish yet. And I just like, oh, I want to win bra rule number 45 create your rock bottom
When someone tells me, you know Lois, I've got a really good job. I'm making a 130 grand a year
I've been doing it for 20 years. I got a you know, really good life good kids good wife
It's just that something's missing and they got those like golden handcuffs. Right? Were they the good life, but it's not outstanding
Yeah, what do you say to those individuals who are like, it's hard to really they don't want to hit rock bottom
I got a good life. Yeah, but and it's really tough to break through that topic man
I just had this conversation with like my number one client in the world and that's my son
You know, we just had to stop and I said son you are probably at the most dangerous part of your life
He's like dad. I've got three months and I graduate from college like that. What what time is though?
You know, I want a dad. Oh, I was an Elite Eight ringer Final Four ring dad
I got a job offer of a lifetime and I like that's the problem
I'm like everything you've ever dreamed of you are three months away
So what happens three months in one day like you have nothing son?
Like I said, so what you have to do for me is not I need you to start all over from scratch
I need you to come up with what's the next four years look like
What's the I'm like, is it getting 800 credit score? Is it saving?
$250,000. Is it finding the girl you're dreaming getting married, you know, is it buying a house helping your mom?
I'll pay for your sister to go to school my son. I don't care what it is, but you don't understand
This is dangerous because this is where people mess up
They get comfortable they saddle and they think yo, I made it and like you said that's the worst place in the world
So I told my son like yo, just imagine in three months
You're gonna wake up and every dream you've had since you were 6 or 7 years old
It's like who graduates with the dream job? You know who who lives in New York? Who's he's a man?
He's gonna be a Manhattan Times Square, you know, so I said son, this is a dangerous place
So I say to those individuals you're you right. You don't want to hit rock bottom
But you have to create your own mental rock bottom so that you don't hit rock bottom
rule number 46 think critically
Let's talk about what you know again average versus phenomenal when people are met with opposition
What do you what do you do? What do you do with your average? And what do you do with your phenomenal?
I think of your average
You play into?
The situation, you know, I'm just saying so like let's say it's perceived as negative
Like you go there, you know you go with all he hating on me or she hating on me. I'll give you a prime example
when I was average I saw my wife's treatment of my gift as
Opposition like Yoshi and supported me. You know, I'm saying like Oh, am I here speaking?
You know I'm saying like every time I speak she critiquing me, you know
She never said none positive about my presentation like every time I get offstage
if it's the best that I thought I ever did she like what you should have done this you shouldn't have said that like
Come on, you know better than that you didn't I'm just like yo, what's up? Like where's the support?
You know that was average, you know
great was
She going to work when I'm working on becoming a motivational speaker. I should go to work every day
So she supported you you got health insurance because she had health insurance. She got a 401k
She's built up a bank account. She got a phenomenal credit score and got us a house her credit score
Said no, but when I was average it was like you're not doing what I want you to do, but when I became great
I realized you know, I already got 40 people that just said that was a phenomenal message
You don't get better by people telling you what you did right you get better by watching the film
You get better by critiquing yourself. So here's a person who's brave enough to
Critique me, because somebody else might have thought the same thing, but they weren't gonna say nothing to me about it
You know I'm saying so just looking at the situation like, you know, don't look at it average people
Look at you know what it is. They don't critical think they don't analyze they don't they don't they don't unpack
You know what I'm saying? Like they just see that's blue and not go deeper into
Well, actually that could be whatever it is. Yellow and purple whatever colors big blue light. This is what this really is
So for me average taking everything as it was, you know victim
phenomenal Victoire and seeing possibilities
Seeing beyond, you know, what surf is that to me?
That's one of the characteristics that determine a person who's average versus somebody who's great rule number 47 be humble
You got to be humble, you know
And I think too many of us who've been blessed like we've been blessing
People watch us and don't see the humility like they would prefer to see you know the confidence in us
You know the passion and overlook like the humility, but when you're humble
That's how you see things that other people don't see like when you're a humble you see you're out running water
You know I'm saying I've been to other countries where they don't have running water, you know, you know
We all have a roof already. This is a different type of roof
Yes, you're upset
but but you can look at this every day and see the water and just go like
You're just a gift
Because how many people have tried to do the exact same thing you tried to do in the exact same way you try to do
It and it didn't end up like this. So I wake up every day
Like, you know II you've been married 20 somebody you've been married almost 28 years like somebody took a chance on you
You know said and I'm being real like her mom was like don't do it. Her father was like don't do it
Like what does he have? He doesn't have anything. That's a gift when somebody
Loves you when you don't have absolutely anything and then now it's a gift to be with somebody
Who's not with me?
Because I'm eating it by preaching but really has been with me like in the good the bad the ugly
So I know this my rider died. So I think gifts are all around us. But some people aren't humble enough to say
Yeah, I did work for this one. But this one let's just be honest. Yeah, I didn't work for this one
Yeah, this was a gift from God
This was given to me and I gotta be humble and be grateful tell you rule number 48 change your mindset
It's all mental when people don't get it. Everybody wants to say okay. We're here go 10 steps to okay?
Lewis said do 8 et
Said do nine, you know this person says this to 12 steps and everybody's trying to get two steps without the mentality
It's like, okay, maybe you don't need all nine, or maybe you don't need all eight. Maybe need four. Maybe you need 12
I don't know but I think sometimes they see what we do and say if I can if if like if I can duplicate that
Just like exactly how he does in the book exactly and it's like, you know, you have a story
You know you have a unique experience and so your 12 are shaped by by not just your world
But how your world has shaped your thinking and I think that's the part that missions like guys, you know
If it was easy, everybody could do it if it was a cookie cutter
Everybody would just follow it to the tea, but there's a mindset and when I looked at Serena
You know when I look at the Michael Jordan's already Tom Brady
You know when you look at Michael Phelps like it is a mentality
You know on our new album the resolution I talk about I got that dog, and I'm not really referring to just this, you know
Aggressiveness but it is a mindset. I saw Belichick said something where you never like how you feeling about the super boys
I'm gonna be honest with you with five weeks behind
Everybody else next year next year - is practicing training they lost
You know, they they and so they're trying to get ready lifting weights that reading book. They're you know, everybody that lost the study
It's like yeah, we found what type of mind set is in five weeks behind in super simple
But again, it's a mentality and I think a lot of people are missing that mentality rule number 49 know your audience
people do what they do outside of the people they're doing it for because the weirdest thing is like
People self. Okay, like I'm a great speaker. Who told you you were great
Like what was it?
The people that you were talking to the day tell you were great or did just you just make up in your own mind
You're great. And so I spent a lot of time. What do the people want to hear? What are they? What are their challenges?
What are they going through so when you see me at a Michigan State steel?
you know when you still see me at
as a at a prison or you know at a
shelter
I'm doing that because I need to be I need to know the pulse of the people that I'm talking to
And there are a lot of people they get they like they do a shot outside of the people that they're doing it for
That's one of things. I appreciate about you when I was talking to you about. You know, my wife's health
you know, it was a
Oke, let's talk about what like not some just our EMS
It's like oh, okay. What's your wife what's didi going through right now? What is she
Experiencing, you know, because there are people who talk to me about MS
I'm like, you know my wife not in the wheelchair, you know
I'm saying like you're talking to me like my wife like and
And I know people who are but like you're talking to me like my wife was in a wheelchair like you
You have not gotten to know my wife it so you're giving me some information
Not based on what she is really going through right now
so we need to talk about what and I just think a lot of people when they do their work Shawn they don't care about
the people that they're actually working for they're so consumed with the work itself and
speaking that it's like oh
it's so easy for me to do what I do because I spend 30 40 hours with people and then when I talk I only
talk about what they told me the more the year and rule number 50 the last one before a very special bonus clip is
Dream big but get small wins
And I want people to understand this dream big but get small wins
Don't okay. I'm saying dream big but get the small wins and no smart
Never forget here in John Elway's speak
Once you know John Elway was like, you know, I became great by being good over a long period of time, you know
and so for me it was
Alright get he's leaving. She's going to college if I can get my GED
That's that's all I need to focus on right now is let me get the GED and here's the thing
I never realized by having a girlfriend. It was like I'm not dating anybody selling dope
I'm not dating anybody just you know violent, you know, I'm not dating nobody's carrying a gun. So for me
Yeah, so for me, it was like I didn't even know about being with her
It stopped me from doing some of the stuff that had I not had a purpose
I probably would have been doing what my boys was doing because I was with them
I just wasn't doing what they were doing, you know
So the GB was the first win then I ended up following her going to college now
First college was Oakland went to a very small school in Alabama
but then after I finished that and I was speaking at the time and so now universities are like
University of Cincinnati saumui University of
Louisville, Michigan State
So Michigan State can't say all these these guys like you but we won't accord you like we want you to come get a degree
And eventually work for the university. So I'm thinking high school dropout
You know, I got a four-year degree
I go to Michigan State like I can make my momma try to get I'm from Detroit
So it's you a veil or it's Michigan State and so I'm like, you know
I can reverse this to my little sister went to U of M
So if I go to your Michigan State my mom that's like house money. Yeah
I was like mom could be proud of me again because you know, of course leaving home, you know, we get into it
You know, it's a point where my mom was kind of discouraged
Like I didn't raise you like this, you know, so to go to Michigan State get a master's degree
It's like y'all have to make mama proud and then when she came to the graduation I decided I might hey
I might as well get the PhD, you know this let's just finish it up
Bring her back one more time and some of the pain that I caused her
I'm sure another degree is only gonna make her that you don't much more. So I just say man start with the small wins
Now I've got a really special bonus Eric Thomas clip on how to surround yourself with greatness that I think you're really gonna enjoy but
Before that I want to know what did you learn today? You just sat through 50 different bolding nuggets from et
the man
What was the one that had the biggest impact on you what change you're gonna make in your life or business as a result of?
Watching this video leave it down the comments below. Don't just wash another video not take action
Write it down when you write it down. You're more likely to take that action. So put it in the comments
Thank you guys so much for watching. I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in yourself and whatever. Your one word is much. Love. I'll see you soon. And enjoy the bonus clip
And you didn't really have a lot of money growing up right, no, not at all
So, how did you learn from someone who never made money really to?
Build wealth. How was that for you? Did you learn from someone? Did you tell you I figure it out in the books?
Come on, let's be real you got the the the Napoleon Hills. Yeah think of your rich on top
That's my that's the one man, you know
You know the richest man in Babylon, I got that
Yeah, so, you know all the classics man, but for me then I started meeting Dan Gilbert
I started meeting Bob Proctor and I was saying like I don't want to meet you get the check from these guys
I want to sit down and learn from these guys
So a lot of those guys have done it and then we've been fortunate to have our own, you know
Financial guru now with Josh, you know being a part of the team, you know
So looking at things from a financial standpoint cuz I'll be honest
I always look the stuff from a ministry standpoint, you know in ministry is good, but it's not a business, you know
So now we have a business model, you know things are happening
So I got around the right people man and was honest
Let me talk about ego was humble enough to say I don't know and I'm not gonna pretend like I know right, you know
Cuz sometimes you're like I don't know you like you get these people around you and you try to act like you know
You know people did you read that book I talked to
They never read a book a day. Like no. No, like I don't know, you know, and then we need your help
So I've just surrounded myself with the with the people who know I do well and what I do
Well that and I let the people who do well or what they do. I'll give them free reign to do what they do
If you tell yourself a story long enough, you start to believe it don't you believe it? You act like I am Tulsa
What a wail out of handcuffed lightning throw thunder in jail. Now, you know, I'm bad over the last week
I murdered a rock into the stone
Hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make medicine sick
the fundamental
Key to success
is it can take between
Eighteen and two hundred and fifty four days of taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 2:54 confidence or every single day for
254 days
I will be sending you a video between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long that you start your morning with around making you feel
confident it's
Absolutely free. Check out the link in the description below to get access